bonsoir battant le kenya merci d'être
avec nous au royaume-uni donc 50% des
cas ce serait des cas de variants indien
il ya de quoi être inquiet comment
l'expliquer oui deux non homologué celle
habituelle des virus des variants
apparaissent dans le monde entier et
parfois ils sont plus contaminant et
aurait eu ni bien sûr nous avons une
importation de kck générer de nouveaux
cas sur place et comme ces variants est
plus contagieux nous avons plus de 50
cas il faut contrôler et essayer
d'endiguer la propagation est le royaume
uni qui on le sait vaccine beaucoup plus
vite qu'ailleurs en europe
ça veut dire quoi que le variant indien
va plus vite que le vaccin on n'en est
pas là we not be in d'abord c'est très
important dans les laboratoires du bonus
les anticorps générés par le vaccin
semble être efficace contre le vaio
indien sur le terrain il faut encore
voir si le parieur indien et bien
neutralisé par les vaccins utilisés
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il ne semble
pas à ce jour il s'agit de résultats
après lumière et disco le canadien l'eau
qui ne semble pas être plus virulent
mais il est effectivement sans doute
plus contaminant pour les âges les plus
jeunes viande qu'il pourrait y avoir
plus de jeunes
malade et certains d'entre eux se
retrouvent en l'hôpital donc plus 30 a
lieu mais pas plus dangereux si je vous
écoute vous parliez de l'efficacité des
vaccins lesquels aujourd'hui sont dits
efficace face à ce variant on parle de
pfizer à ce que c'est aussi le cas des
vaccins dit adénovirus tels que
astrazeneca ou johnson johnson me
donnait les axéens 13h moderna et
astrazeneca se sont tous révélés dans
une situation de laboratoire à efficace
contre le varia indien de et nous
espérons que cela s'appliquera également
dans la nature entre guillemets que le
vaccin protégera bien contre le brillant
alors le vario indien qui inquiète au
royaume uni qui entament pourtant une
nouvelle étape de son déconfinement
entre autres la réouverture des bars et
des restaurants à l'intérieur est-ce que
ça inquiète l'épidémiologiste que vous
êtes
ja oui ça fait je suis très inquiète
effectivement je redoute que les
personnes vulnérables à des personnes
qui ont des collants bilité sont déjà
mis musée mais les jeunes personnes les
jeunes gens n'ont pas encore être
immunisé donc se retrouver avec beaucoup
de personnes à l'intérieur sans autre
vacciner cela représente un risque
je le conseillerai donc aux jeunes aux
personnes qui n'ont pas été vaccinés de
réduire la circulation leur présence en
intérieur mieux vaut rester à
l'extérieur
et mieux vaut attendre jusqu'à ce qu'on
puisse être vaccinés c'est une toute
petite précaution mais elle vaut
vraiment la peine
johnson at il fermé au bon moment
l'accès aux offrant aux voyageurs un
bien c'était le 19 avril dernier alors
que le pakistan et le bangladesh avait
déjà mis en place cette restriction trop
tard pour vous oui je suis le gone in
effectivement il aurait fallu agir plus
tôt et ont pour se disputer
éternellement les mon point de vue il
experts c'est que à partir du moment où
on a appris qu'il avait un nom un large
temps large nombre de cas en inde et que
les variants elle aurait dû être mis sur
liste rouge
en france on est aussi inquiet par ce
variant indien certains experts un peu
catastrophique et imagine un été
particulièrement meurtrier en cas de
relâchement total des restrictions il
est vrai qu'en france on pratique
beaucoup moins que vous le séquençage
vous êtes inquiet un pour nous français
sommes tout à fait je suis très inquiète
pour l'union européenne pour de
nombreuses raisons
car l'union européenne et notre voisine
et c'est très décevant que le programme
vaccinal euros père ne soit pas pas
suffisant je suis attristé
l'union européenne n'est pas assez
rapide n'est pas aussi rapide que le
royaume uni et j'espère qu'elle nous
rattrapera bientôt et vaccinera aussi
rapidement que le royaume uni je suis
profondément inquiet pour l'union
européenne et la france
je redoute votre avenir sachant que la
population n'est pas immunisée et qu'on
se retrouve face à un virus plus
contaminés en donc faites vous vacciner
si vous
les portes et vos masques et go de plus
allez acheter des masques de meilleure
qualité et porter correctement une
dernière petite question de plus en plus
on reparle de cette thèse du virus
échappé d'un laboratoire
c'est vrai que avant c'était un petit
peu tabou ça revient à la surface de
manière plus franche est ce que ça vous
étonne vos noms je peux l'expliquer de
manière tout à fait scientifique parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de contamination dans
le monde entier il y aura une apparition
de variants il ya eu deux variants venue
du brésil de l'afrique du sud du caire
et c est cela montre les plus taux de
contamination est trop élevé partout
dans le monde
et quand trop de personnes sont
contaminées comme il ya trop de virus
produit alors forcément il ya de
nombreux variés qui apparaissent l'un
après l'autre
donc ce n'est pas une question d'origine
artificielle du virus le problème c'est
que l'on ne contrôle pas la
contamination dans toutes les régions du
monde
merci barre à toi pendant kenya d'avoir
répondu à nos questions en direct sur
arte france